ladies in climb good morning world
conference center von der leyen maximum
in the hand merci beaucoup azzurra tumor
on the bow or projectors at the event was
articulated reconstruction
economic methusalem reseller var grill
academy wikipedia premium as well as the
premium only mixed at the maximum of the
png bmp rapid motives  since two
flows built very positive
development which would like to share
with you know we have access to three
hundred million doses biontech way
grow or good news is totally on
current technology trades million
doses biotech way grow
the mount on dose to 1 5 million  on
the or- advantage of disco news is
contact between the
sexy for the spring searching for the
planet critical moments for
vaccination to audio answers about good
news commission sec and the new york
following the coming weeks and man and
it therefore remains that europe will be more
than have enough vaccine in a
reliable timer  aum and that also shows
that the path we have taken together
in europe is the
right path we want to do it
together we have the power of the
common market this is proven
again today
we have created a broad
portfolio of vaccines together that
was also right  because who knew
in the summer which vaccine would win the race at the end
we need a
broad portfolio
we, as
the european commission, have invested in expanding capacities right from the start
this also shows today
how important it is
and we are now involved together with 27
member states  promoting this vaccination in the
process
because it is also right and we know
that we are all only safe if
everyone in europe also has access to the
vaccine and our neighborhood no
country in europe can do without the others we
have a large community of values ​​in
europe we would be together  market in
europe and we are coming out of this deep state of
health  its and economic crisis only out
together we are stronger if
we stick together
[music]
maxim
okay the woman von der leyen there has been a
lot of criticism of the eu in the last few
weeks
the eu ordered too little vaccine relied
on the wrong manufacturers and
negotiated with too little
willingness to take risks, this contract with biontech is now,
so to speak, an admission that the eu
has hitherto been wrong and what
would you do differently in retrospect?
the european union has taken absolutely the
right path and we
should not forget that we
always have 27 with us  27 member
states made together every step was
coordinated together and i am
deeply convinced that is the right way
is we must not forget in the summer of
this year and that
less than six months ago we had over 160
different vaccine candidates
trying to advance research
bring and develop a vaccine
that were ge  massive numbers and from
those 160 and more we
filtered out the six deals
we have today and you all know
those six deals were the right
focus because
they not only include biotec and modern
but also astrazeneca johnson
johnson we have choral work and we have  there is
sanofi in there and these are all
products that have made good progress.
secondly, we did exactly the
right thing together, namely that the
european commission got involved
in all these contracts that
the 27 member states then
made in the summer from the outset
invested in production if we hadn't
done that, we wouldn't have these
large numbers today either. it wo
n't be possible. you have to invest
in expanding capacities so that in
the situation where the vaccine was then
successful, these
million doses could actually be produced
quickly  and we walked this path
together also because we know
we had to develop a common vaccination
strategy we wanted to
manage the logistics together and it is evident
today that this is the right way
we will not be
able to coordinate this additional doubling of the doses with bayern text today if
if we hadn't all made these investments in expanding capacities together in the summer
the european investment
bank has given a loan of over 100 million
the european commission has
invested in expanding capacities
not only at by and tech wise
but at all the others with whom we
we have contracts and today
we can see that we can reap them i am deeply
convinced that this european way is the
right one and i think in
retrospect it will prove
that there is a second point that
i think is not seen enough
it works too  not only about us in
europe but it  It's also about our
neighborhood.
It's about
being able to ensure that
our neighborhood also
has the opportunity to get vaccines.
The countries that don't have the
financial means
also need our support and
help, and if they do  look at what
our portfolio looks like today
these six different contracts that
we have
if they all come into effect then
we will have a total volume of 2.3
billion vaccine doses yes
sometimes you have to vaccinate twice so that does
n't matter you can't translate that into
vaccinations per se  but this is a
large portfolio that shows that we will have more
than enough vaccine and
that we and this is europe not only
think of ourselves but that we also
think of our neighborhood our environment that we also think of other countries
that need more support
[  Music]
[Music]
risk to lose the report fans in kelso
pol  itiker kreises germany grow
grow grow grow grow means
[music]
taxi nation on course how did you get the
benchmark index s what i saw the
challenges as fast as possible
the time we have maxi nations population
is between the next generation
recovery craft with italy
government like any  other government to
quickly and progress and conditions and
investment director roof and the uncle
's flag story so collaborator lastrup
no on the contrary
it proves that our steps were
correct because please do
n't forget that the bayern tag
itself announced at the beginning of december
that you  global global cut your delivery in
half that was an announcement by the
company itself
because like everyone else you
were faced with the situation that the
demand is huge but the
production capacities have not yet
kept pace
now a good further step
is coming, namely as you can also see from the press
the
production  beyond advisor's capacities
are being expanded that's good
and that's important is a process that
we support with all our might
and based on this
decision it's also
possible to enter into an extension of the contract and
that shows that it was the right thing
to do with this horse  if
i may say so,
having biotec wiser in the portfolio with the other
five it was right from the start
for us to invest in the expansion of production capacities
i think this point is always
overlooked we will not be where
we are today  if we hadn't
invested in the expansion of
production capacities, we now have this harvest in which we
see new production
facilities being opened or authorized
and this also enables us on the
trusting good basis on which we work
together with buy and texter
this enables us
then also get this doubling of the contract
peter
kapern thank you very much for the opportunity to
ask a question
madam president basically
i have two short questions one is there
is also massive criticism of the
implementation of the strategies just given or of
the implantation of strategies in the
member states in bavaria you can hear that
vaccines had to be destroyed
because they were transported in technically inadequate camping
coolers
in the
netherlands vaccination started hesitantly this week in
france it doesn't work either
i remember that the commission
asked the member states i think it was already asked in october
in strategies  to develop
why that is my first question
member
states are failing in the development of these vaccine
strategies where what what where is there the
mistake and the other question
is again aimed at the criticism of
the vaccine purchases at the
commission
which is accused of the eu
Commission  at a time when it was
foreseeable that the vaccine from
baxter is very promising and 200
million more doses
would have been available this purchase that the
commission had not made this purchase at that time
was that so if
so why
then took action so we have something in the
strategy  concerns indeed discussed this with the member states at an early stage
and
the strategy also means that you have to
prioritize the fact
that we said from the outset that
according to the recommendations of the
experts from the
health sector but also from the
whu, we recommend in the vaccination strategy
First of all,
nursing staff over 65 years of age prioritize the
residential groups. You know
that. That shows that it was clear from the start that
you can't
vaccinate everyone at once, but it will go step by step
, and the second thing we've
emphasized again and again and what's changing
now  shows that these will be very
difficult months  in the spring
because we have two developments the
slower increase in the number
of vaccinations so that the number of
vaccinated people is increasing but that
is a slow increase
and secondly that the
infection process is still very
worrying that is exactly the
moment we are experiencing now  and that's why
i'm also convinced that if
we look back one day
we'll see yes at the beginning there was a bam
pii rot a a a bumpy
road that's always the case with such
big changes that you
tackle but in retrospect i'm the one  the firm
conviction that you will see that a
lot has been done here in the
member states to actually get the vaccination on the
way and secondly
we have all decisions about purchases
and we make them together with the
member states and we always need
texaners from bavaria as well  like away from cure
or more modern or johnson johnson
o  the astrazeneca the mix of
offers but it must also be credibly
possible that it will be
delivered in the time we need it
for us it is important that you can
understand that
the offer will come in the fourth quarter
but that or in the year 2022  that we
now have the vaccines at the beginning when we
need them and that is why i
repeat again at and texter
now the happy moment comes together
that it is possible to expand the vaccine production
and therefore also succeed in implementing
an increase on a proven contract
growing up
this is  to grow grow grow
grow grow
usingen